we unleashed something powerful we have
to stop her
did you want to do something right you
make a list we have to team two we got
to fight ghost three we're gonna track
down ghosts
that seems like she'd be part of two to
a
[Music]
Oh also we have to save the world that's
major we can't forget that so how long
have you been Antonin again no I I just
sort of happened it's like bad guys like
you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
like walks to walls and stuff
slowly uptick and now she wants to take
over the world or whatever who would
have believed that in your hour of need
you would turn the house happy because
we brought you do you member that's us
feeling chesty bad video
and man the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you two
are finished comparing sizes 65
[Music]